the jurogan experience so they lead you
from a hut
you're staying down they stop they go
stop listen
to the insects in the river he goes
that's going to be amplified soon
you know okay he comes and they the
woman
uh the shaman wears his headdress and
and she beats you with these leaves and
rubs
says whatever chance he says and rubs a
stone all over you
gives you the ayahuasca tastes like
[ __ ] ass
tastes like whatever's left in this
ashtray and you just drink it down
they say your partner other side of the
fire you're on this side of the fire
you don't talk he's having his trip
you're having hit your trip that's it um
you might throw up because that is the
ayahuasca doesn't make a trip the
ayahuasca takes everything out of you
and then the chong
i haven't written down actually
was the oh that's a different drug yeah
so ayahuasca clears you unless the
chacruna
in this case do it they showed they
showed me where the ios came from
planted 80 years before
they planted it so drank it i'm laying
there
on a mat just like a thin thin mat next
to this fire in this like
hut hut um i
i i'm a bit worried about like anacondas
and jaguars and stuff but like
um so she says the shaman says i'm your
mother
here the ayahuasca the root is your
grandmother
my son who's training to be a shaman he
is your brother
and the fire is your ancestors um
so i drank it he said stare at the fire
for about five minutes then go lay down
my partner started throwing up 10
minutes in
going to the edge there's two entrances
to the thing throw it up i
just wasn't coming it wasn't coming a
little bit of like a light
cap and a stem mushroom feel for about
i don't know hour and a half or so and
then i started getting nauseous but i'm
sorry
i'm trying to choke it down like don't
don't and then it hit me like oh i think
i'm supposed to like
supposed to throw up so i kind of like
pitch black i mean away from the fire
went to the the edge
and then like you know how you can like
sort of like and then barked like a
little bit
and then just unloaded i was afraid it
would be like
wretching and wretching it wasn't that
um just like unloaded
and then he's right there the shaman's
like trainee
son with a bowl of water he goes swish
around don't drink it
and he goes uh are you having visions
dude i don't know how he was
i don't know how he's communicating
because he didn't
i barely speak spanish and he barely
speaks spanish
but enough i guess
i was like he was like are you having
visions and i was like yeah they're more
like kind of mental
like mental mushrooms mental and he goes
okay go back be strong
i don't know how he was conveying this
to me
but he was like okay go be strong go lay
down there and like
you have to like be strong so then it
just
opened up and so more than an hour and a
half in
more than an hour and a half in of a
seven hour trip wow
um yeah it took a while
the partner was going immediately but
like uh
i see these like fractals and like an
geometric shapes and occasionally like
splashes of and this is the thatch
roof of the hut right so nothing's there
and an occasional like
real splash of like vivid neon light
and then i started seeing these like
orbs kind of like
going up into the fractals and then
the more i looked forward and back i'm
on my back but more like forward
backwards side to side there's just
hundreds or thousands of these these
orbs these small orbs going
up into the fractals and just sort of
like playing with each other
these orbs they were kind of like had a
life to him
so like and then at some point from me
comes this orb and sort of like
goes up and then i started examining
what the orbs are
so look i don't know i don't know about
any of this stuff
but this is just what it gave me i don't
know you know same as mushrooms i don't
know if it's just scientific or if it's
like
another realm whatever right
the orbs were
i call it when you pure something when
you pure it
to me they were they were moments of of
pure artistic expression
you ever have a like a set
or or or a roll where you're like i hit
every [ __ ] move you get in the zone
you're in the zone sure
you pureed it you know uh uh in golf
jamie you might know
it's like when you [ __ ] hit one and
you're just like [ __ ]
like up but you're like i can't hit the
green from here you do see it go
perfectly
and bounce and it's just a pure moment
of artistic expression and generally
when i see that it makes me cry
when i listen to never mind i i start i
tear up you know you ever hear that
album when you're like oh this is
they nailed it they nailed it they
nailed it uh uh uh
cigar de familia in barcelona this
church that was it's being built still
it's a 200-year plan to build this the
perfect church
saint peter's basilica in rome okay and
you see it stunning
and i walked in there i just thought i
mean i started weeping start crying yeah
it's like i don't i don't know it's just
like it's overwhelmingly perfect
it's art yeah other moments i was at um
the um it didn't have to be big moments
it could be small moments i was at the
um
haunted ride at disney back in l.a
and i was with some chick and i was like
some guy was like right this was the
you know and like pitch he's playing the
role whatever and then like he left to
go greet the next like
car and as we were slowly moving forward
and then i was like okay i was creepy
right
and then he was back on me just going
what did you say it just like frightened
me and
that guy nailed it in that moment we
were both [ __ ]
jumped he [ __ ] nailed it right he
pureed it
and what you want in those moments you
did it right you made this thing and
that's the orb
and what you want is to make it for sure
what you also want is some recognition
you want someone to say like if you hit
that golf shot you look around like if
you're playing by yourself and somebody
that next he's like
dude [ __ ] nice one you're like yes
thank you you saw it you saw it
right so
there's been two things i've gotten that
way two things that i've had that i'm
like
i i pureed it um
one was that storytelling show this is
not happening
i i just think it was like
i i mean i don't i don't want to talk
about myself but like it was cool and it
you know it was a way for for other
comics to show themselves
i can express it for you you did an
amazing thing and those
opening sequences where you'd have like
these animated fight scenes and [ __ ]
they were awesome
they're cool it just made it cool and
fun to watch and let people go hey we're
not going to censor you
right we want you to do your thing your
[ __ ] uh strip club in the woods story
is like these moments that
i'm also allowing other people to like
so i figured out my orbs what i do is
make stuff myself and then also give a
chance for other people to make theirs
it's one of my things i like making
you have the same thing you like having
other people make their things that's
one of your art forms
is allowing other people to make their
art
another one was this last hour i did the
jew hour
it was it was good it was really [ __ ]
it was good
and so it would have bothered me at the
time i wasn't able to like make it as
special
but i was able in that moment to go but
i made it
it was good you know i made a a really
[ __ ]
really mindful kind of perfect thing and
yeah maybe whatever happened like i
wasn't able to make like millions of
people saw it but like
thousands of people saw it maybe 150 000
people saw it
live you know but like i made it
and i cried hard for that for this not
happening
not so much that like for the loss but
for like
for like when i was able to purity i was
able to step back
and go like it's done now i made it and
it hit me like
oh damn dude that was [ __ ] good
and i just kind of said goodbye to it
and that orb went up
and and played for eternity every time
you do something like artistically pure
like that
and nail it you pure it those things are
up there
in the heavens in the whatever
they're playing with each other all the
forms the guy at disney
the guy who made the basilica uh
[ __ ] kurt cobain never mind not kirk
robin never mind
is up there playing with each other
enjoying each other's company forever
and i saw myself in 50 years dead
and the orbs are still playing and i'm
decaying and the orbs are still playing
they'll be there forever
and i was able to sort of like put that
behind me and say i'll move on to my
next thing because what i
want to do is i want to make things
right i want to make another orb and
that's
kind of all i want to do now is just
make another thing and i won't always
get there but even if you fail
even if you're like ah that set was so
so you know what's getting you closer to
a [ __ ] perfect set and sometimes it's
just a 15-minute set
at the [ __ ] whatever club you know
uh governors or some [ __ ] where it's
like oh i [ __ ] nailed it sometimes
it's a 10-minute
pop-in you're like that earthquake thing
that i saw at the haha
that was one because there was some kid
some young one-year comic watching that
going like oh my god
he [ __ ] pureed it in that moment yeah
but you wanted someone to [ __ ]
notice it once in a while you just you
do
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience